joining us now former speaker the house
Fox News contributor Newt Gingrich Newt
that pained that kendallenium NBC to
actually have to report that but
multiple questions remain outstanding
tonight about all of these classified
documents now a second location correct
look I think what's happening is the
documents are the beginning of the
unraveling of the entire uh Biden
basically criminal family operation
first of all the documents are going to
lead you to the University of
Pennsylvania where the Chinese
Communists gave millions and millions of
dollars they refused to open their books
the president of the University of
Pennsylvania got to be the ambassador to
Germany people like the Secretary of
State the current President Biden got a
million dollars for nine appearances we
have no idea where all the money went we
have no idea what the influence was but
it's ironic that some of these documents
were found at a University of
Pennsylvania office second this leads
you right back to Hunter Biden as The
Bag Man because the docu the first wave
of documents included documents about
Ukraine at about the time that Hunter
Biden was getting hired by barisma the
Ukrainian Energy company largely because
he was the son of the vice president so
that's going to all be wrapped up
together and then finally this makes an
absurdity of the attack on Donald Trump
uh the fact is Biden can't tell you and
they've said this openly he has no idea
who had the documents he has no idea
what documents we're talking about now
imagine we're talking about a very
secret documents which the current
president United States
openly says somehow somebody somewhere
got them and they took them away and he
has no clue which also says to me if the
FBI were serious they would be looking
at all of Biden's multiple homes uh
they'll be looking at all obidon's
offices for the last 10 years just to
figure out what else is there out there
that we haven't seen yet and also not
going to go away it's going to get
bigger and and there was a change today
was there not and the way the Press was
asking questions about this the first
day it was kind of like oh they're
differentiating between you know what
happened with Trump Mar-A-Lago and this
oh they're totally different and now
today you could sense it and I'd like to
know what Susan Rice knew about these
documents Newt because she had her hand
in everything in that Obama White House
she knew where all the bodies were
buried for lack of a better phrase
all of those folks involved in the
National Security Council should be
interviewed and perhaps they will be I
hope they will be
well first of all raises the question
because it gets you right back to the
University of Pennsylvania we know the
secretary of state was being paid by the
University of Pennsylvania we know that
the vice president was being paid how
many people in the current Biden
Administration in the current White
House staff were getting money out of
the University of Pennsylvania and why
will the University of Pennsylvania not
release the finances they claim that the
millions and millions of dollars the
Chinese Communists have given the
university didn't go to Biden fine then
where did the money come from what's the
deal and the fact is and when I was
working on this in the Trump
Administration we could not get them to
tell us the truth they are totally
hiding all this information and I
suspect the new Republican house is
going to subpoena all the documents from
the University of Pennsylvania and
insist that they share with us because I
think this is Way Beyond Joe Biden I
think the huge chunks Administration
remember
this is a habit Sandy Berger the
National Security advisor Bill Clinton
ended up getting ultimately going to
jail because he'd gone to the National
Archive and literally snuck uh documents
that were that were Secret in his socks
and in his underwear and got caught
Hillary Clinton raised 32
000 emails and broke up a hard drive
with a hammer uh you have I'd be very
curious how many documents John Kerry's
had and interestingly the documents that
were initially discovered are documents
that do relate to Ukraine and to Iran
and that relate to Ukraine at a time
when Hunter Biden was The Bag Man for
what is basically a criminal family I
mean the bonds as an operation are would
make perfect sense if you ever saw The
Sopranos you'll understand exactly
what's going on well and who had access
to these documents I mean that question
was posed to the press secretary today
she just I may say she's like talk to
the White House counsel's Office White
House counsel's office is not returning
anyone's calls as far as we could tell
certainly not our um you know Peter
ducey's calls so again was there any
sharing of office space with Hunter
Biden or any you know any Chinese
officials have any access to this space
because obviously they had a lot of
money invested in this uh Biden Pen
Center whatever it was called so these
questions have to be answered Newton I
think you're exactly right this goes Way
Beyond Joe Biden uh to a lot of these
characters and we really appreciate Newt
Gingrich joining us thanks Newt hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else